most people can't comprehend that
someone is doing 50 times more work than
them people do astonishingly little and
that's okay cuz humans are meant to
conserve energy we're predisposed to
laziness there's a time for leverage but
sometimes it's just violence it's just
Brute Force it's forcing the outcome if
you suck at Cold calls do more cold
calls not twice as many do 20 times more
and you'll get better 20 times faster
than you would and I actually think it's
even faster than that cuz if you do 20
times the calls one guy does 3 hours of
calls a week and I do 60 hours of calls
a week so 20 20 times the output it
would taken 20 weeks to get to that same
number of reps but because my feet back
Loops are shorter I also get better
faster I do more work in a shorter
period and then my skill also improves
faster then you look like an outlier on
the map and everyone's like what did
this guy do it's like he literally did
20 times more work